やあみんな dogan ここで、これはこの単語
の発音についての簡単なチュートリアルです。
とても良かったので、最近のビデオで、
英語のネイティブ スピーカーがどのよう
に言う傾向があるかについて話し
ました。
英語を母国語とする私たちは
、無意識のうちに
、日本語の他の単語には
ピッチ アクセント パターン
があるため、簡単に理解できるピッチ アクセント パターンを持っ
ているため、これらの単語
もそれらのルールに従っていると思い込んでいますが
、それは正しくなく、似たようなものです。
繰り返しになりますが、この単語
は英語のネイティブ スピーカーとして良かったです。
ピッチ アクセント パターンを拾うのに問題はありません。
また
、ピッチ アクセント パターンを再現する
ことも
できます。おそらく何百回も聞いたことがあると思います
が、 なぜなら、私たちは
これを理解するのに問題がなく
、日本語の勉強を始めるときによく耳にするからですw
無意識のうちにそのパターン
を他の一般的な単語にマッピングし始め
ます。これの良い例がこの単語
です。多くのネイティブスピーカーが日本語を勉強し始めたとき、
私はこれを最初の2
年間行いました。 日本語を勉強していた私
はこの単語を「若かった」と同じピッチ
アクセントパターンで
言ったので、この単語は「
よかった」と同じように良いと
言えますが、これは正しくありません
この単語の正しいピッチアクセントパターン
は
高低低なので
、いくつか入れます
ほとんどの日本語学習者は
、中級および上級レベルに達すると
、この単語の実際のピッチ アクセント パターンを最終
的に理解し始めます。
しかし
、間違ったピッチアクセント
パターンでそれを言う人が非常に多いため、
私はこれらの人々の1人でした。このチュートリアルを作成したかっただけ
です 多くの人
は、この悪い癖
が最初から再発するの
を防ぐことができます。英語を母国語
とする人であれば
、よかたとしてよかったという言葉を言っている可能性が高いですが、
正しいピッチ アクセントのパターンは、実際には
よかった
ものです。 より多くのネイティブ レコーディング
が役に立ったことを願っています。またお会いしましょ
う。